Let's jump right back in Shelby for September now and probably October as well.
Starting off with the classic, set the indicator up.
This is 11 till 2.
Okay, so we are bearish so we're looking for shorts, plain and simple, from a
news perspective,
no news.
So, let's see what we get from New York, nope, okay, moving to Tuesday is still
bearish.
So today we have ISM at 10, nope, we've now shifted lower, that was accidental.
So that is 8.30, it's 9 true, that's ISM, that's a London, this is now a swing
high, nice
localisation here, this is a buy-side look what it built up but looks like we
've already
shifted bearish, most definitely, so New York needs to give a London, sorry,
needs to give
a continuation, like that, same one a.m.
This is a tag, set and break even, set and break even, and break even,
exceptional management
again, that's a frank sweep continuation, so it's a strong point of interest,
trend is
a strong point, it's a strong point of interest, a strong point of interest, a
strong point
of interest, a strong point of interest, a strong point of interest, a strong
point of
interest, maybe we go attempt number two, pretty much the entire M5 bearish
order block, after
a sweeper Frankfort, tagged, honestly in an ideal world I wouldn't want to move
stops
the Reiki one, I know M15 everything is efficient, nothing to mitigate, M5,
sorry, M15, could
argue that that's to be mitigated, but even if it was to be mitigated let's say
for example,
let's have a look at this, let's say that was to be mitigated, price trades out
, doesn't
break, I'd still probably move my stops above the highs, New York, we have jol
ts at 10,
there's jolts, yeah, can't complain with the management, again, like I said,
could have
argued that that should be kept open, but even if it was kept open, it would
have ended
up coming back to Reiki even, so yeah, that's two break evens to start, but
both with really
and truly exceptional management, still in that strong point of interest, trend
was trending.
So, we're not bullish, we have already had a sweep.
Let me just double check, high, low, high, low, pull back, doesn't mean that we
anyway
break, this is the high, we break bullish, that's the high, then that's the
high, then
we break, then we obviously have a pullback, we break, we break, we break, we
break, yeah,
cool, so we're on point, this would be the swing high, obviously pretty
difficult trade,
let's say for September, we have ISM at 10, we do break, but like how do I
trade it,
this is honestly a little bit unorthodox, it's really not a clean setup.
Basically entering another fair value gap, just using this lowers protection,
also incorporating
this order block, as you can see, not the most ideal trade at all, this is the
type of trade
as well that I would note down, so if I was independently data tested in
certain variables,
might have setups that are like, hey, this is a little bit unorthodox, let's
have a look
at the characteristics of this, could also potentially argue that the entry is
here,
I'm going to stop listed down here, but we'll use the fair value gap, and I got
some break
even, I can go to break even, well, I can at least remove risk, originally $18,
000 worth
of risk, now we have $8,000, so we've cut off at least 50%, which is again
still good
management, and yeah, again, like I said, somewhat unorthodox, to be honest
with you,
oh wow, okay, that may be the first example of where our management has cost us
, so let's
go ahead, but at the same time, like it's such an unorthodox trade, obviously
it goes
to show that the setup works, covering London low was really my play, but yeah,
we can journal
and we can kind of add a little bit of detail here as well, so, and you'll get
that, you'll
get trades that obviously you're monitoring hinders, this is the really
important thing,
is that I'm not going to side quest so much, but some traders, they're not
actually data
driven traders, they're kind of emotional driven traders, and what happens is
they take
a trade and they have something like this, they take a trade, trade starts from
them in
profit, they move their stop loss to manage that position, and then trade comes
, hits their
stop loss, they take a bit of a loss, and then price runs to their target, now,
instead
of being a data driven trader, what that trader does is like, this happened, I
lost
money, therefore, it doesn't work, and they use one scenario to kind of justify
a future
action that they're willing to take, how do you even call this trade, don't be
that
bad, because for every one of these that we've had, and we may have more, think
about how
many break evens have saved us countless amounts of losses, think about how
many cut
in half of the risk, so we look, I've got like X amount of losses, but let's
say we've
got 50 losses on our books, and our average loss is like 0.6 R, right, that's
20% that
we've saved due to the management, so 20% on managing the position to take a
smaller
loss than originally planned on, and another let's say 30% saved on break evens
that have
saved us losing money, you put that together, like that's the make or break of
a system,
like it's, yeah, trend is change of the character, structure of those void,
bring your discount
up, nuke, execution window, three to four, going to make sure I thought, tag in
bang
on three, so we have ISM, now it's nine,
it's a good, it's a good potential set up, we're not going to get tagged anyway
, but
the problem is that, we're still bullish, right,
okay, New York, Friday, the sixth NFP, yep, but a week,
with a bearish, it's too bearish, right, so we're still going to make sure we
're still,
there's two candles, but even if it was three, I wouldn't trade it, wait, I'm
missing a
trade here.
Okay.
So, let's go.
Shouldn't be in this trade, this is the importance of filling out the details
as well, because
I should never be in this trade, I'll explain it now, but why?
Well, first and foremost, obviously bullish, we switch high, we pull back, we
switch the
highs, the change of character occurs here, 159, Frankfurt, what does that mean
?
That means London needs to give this, and London does not give this, thus, it
is an
invalid trade, this is valid though, this is a difficult one, obviously I'm my
entry
area, I want it to be here, but my stop loss, I don't want my stop loss to be
all up here,
I don't want to have an eight pip stop and a damn one to put 1.5 take profit,
like how
is that make any sense?
So, I'm going to be a little bit tricky, my intention is for this to hold, if I
get this
wrong and it tags me in here and trades lower, then I'll make a note, again,
you can also
do, obviously I'm not going to because I don't need to go into that level of
depth, but what
you can also do is for every single, these are session notes, so when you
notice things,
we've already spoke about this, you can add it in here, but trade notes, oh,
never mind,
never mind me, there's a tag, that is in the right direction, I hope my failed
Russian
accents don't offend anyone, my wife is Russian, so, nothing personal, part of
me considers
that as mitigated, the other part mimics it as mitigated, so, by, so,
mitigation, continuation,
I'm going to move my stops to break even, where's 1 to 5, that's break even,
does that
hinder me, yes it does, charge it to the game, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on
a minute,
no I wouldn't take that, so break even, break even here, fine, we trade out
from this, so
even if I didn't move to break even and have my stop loss above this high,
would have come
in, would have traded out, then I would have moved my stop loss here, then
anyway I would
have got tagged out for stop loss, and then obviously runs my direction, so
that's two
times in September that our management has cost us, it is for this, it's
another thing
as well, you can manage, like, track all of your management, see how your
management
strategy, right, everyone gets this confused of thinking that just your entries
, what you
track, or your specific type of setup, no, track your management, right, track
set protocols,
go break even at this point, break even at that point, and then track it, and
then at
the end, collect the data and realize, what's my management profitable or not,
because your
entries are just a part of your edge, every single facet of your playbook of
your edge
can make or break a system, you can have the best system, but in insufficient
management,
and it will turn a great system into an inferior system, you can have
incredible management,
and it can turn an inferior system into a moderately good system, so management
is a
huge part of your process, so track it, see how it affects you, play with
things, have
a hypothesis, what if I go stop to break even here, what about if I move profit
here,
what about my partial here, right, there may be even an efficiency in the way
that I manage,
and then at the end, you can come back and you can see, like, okay, my
management either
cost me this or need me this, and do those rules make sense, just about being a
data-driven
trader, even if I would have entered here, I still would have gotten broke even
.
I don't need to watch through that.
Everyone stay the 11th, inflation rates, no problem, no problem anymore, now we
're bearish
looking for shorts, we're just about to make sure that we don't do it as it
happens.
Take point of interest, of course, well, we are anyway, we're bearish, I'm one,
so that's a way I could highly imagine, so we're bearish and one, so we could
go to internal
because we are still bearish, but it would just have to be "discretion".
Instead of putting my stops at these highs, and almost doubling my risk, I can
put my
stop here because if price runs this high, price is going to probably run this
high
as well, I would give that a very high, probably, and also the rest of the
reward, it's not
the most favourable, again, this is a discretionary trade, technically, tags,
it goes, I would
argue that it's still unmitigated, like the last one was, so I can reduce it
from 17,000
to 10,000, almost half in the position size, if we get a pullback, and then we
go from
here, now I can move my stops to break even because, yeah, I move my stops to
break even,
remember what I said, if this high goes, there's a good chance this high is
going, right now
that hasn't happened, by doing, there you have it, management, m15 pro trend,
yeah, I mean
again all of this is technically one point, it is the playbook.
[ Silence ]
There's not a sweep in there, I'll go and check in a minute anyway but there's,
I can
already see that this is not a way to manage, that was a premature judgment.
That technically is, obviously not a huge fan of the liquidity below, but
collect the
data.
Friday the 30th, Michigan consumer.
All right, thank you very much, everyone.
Thank you.
All right, thank you.
Have a good day.
Thank you.
Bye.
[ Silence ], thank you.
All right, so that's my profit, without me.
Sometimes that's just the way it goes, haven't missed anything.
And then on top of that we have, just Michigan.
That we could tread on here, New York.
Time is out late 30.
It's a really difficult one really, isn't it, because those are all equal lows.
It's a difficult one.
If they're all equal lows, then technically it's the three kind of work,
because the first
candle from this low is this one, British candle, second, third, shift, shift.
So I mean technically it is.
We're coming from a London point of interest, this is a London continuation
model.
It's a really nice setup in terms of accumulation, manipulation, distribution,
negation, continuation.
Also comes from a really nice area of interest.
It's the type of model that you consider as maybe your A+ model.
London sweeps Asia, pro-trend bullish, pullback into discount, point of
interest, lower timeframe
shift with accumulation, manipulation, distribution, mitigation, like it just,
oh, it's a good
trade.
New York has crushed it, by the way, less is more clearly.
This is a New York continuation from London, strong point of interest, New York
.
The trend is Confirm reversal.
So that gives you even more satisfaction, doesn't it?
It does.
Now this where things get tricky, because technically this is the swing low,
but I wouldn't consider
that as a swing low.
I would still use this as a swing low, and so if you trade based off of that, I
guess it's
discretion if we break the low, but I also want to give you insights into how I
'm trading.
Monday 16th of December, September sorry, we're not having any news.
So London session.
Okay, what's going on here then?
1, 2, nope, boom, nope, boom, nope, so this is all just noise, so this is all
just look
cool to see, and the saddest part is, my model wants me to trade up, we'll see
a one structure,
because this is the type of structural range that's difficult to read.
Okay, so we bearish, we bearish, bearish I'm one, which means
New York, I still don't see this as a pocket of liquidity, although it has
swept up, which
would mean that we could trade from it, I still see it as a liquidity pocket.
That was retail sales, I mean okay, okay, okay, hold up a minute.
This price action is horrid, first and foremost, we shift bearish here, shift
bullish, shift
bearish, nope, nope, technically yep, I mean this is technically a setup,
although I don't
like it, but it is a setup, and I'll probably trade this inverted for about a
year up on
the two minute time frame, as you can see sometimes I'm a little bit unorthodox
with
my entries, it's really just about using those time frames, understanding the
order
flow, because it's all the same order flow, doesn't matter what time frame you
're looking
at price on, it's all the same thing, wait, come on then, this is going to melt
off a
cliff, can already see it, just FYI, I don't care how this goes, I would never
take this
in real life, even though yes this sweeps this, this sweeps this, this is a
whole gigantic
bucket load of liquidity, I wouldn't say an advanced, I wouldn't take this,
even if it
trades profitable, I still wouldn't take it, I would never take the trade, that
's where
your own discretion comes in, because you can either try and set a rule for it,
or just
know it, I just know that if price is set on a huge pocket of support liquidity
, I'm
not going to put my stock plus there as well, that's just an obvious principle,
the setup
is, New York sweep London I guess, point of interest, I'm not going to put one,
because
there isn't really one, session is obviously New York, trend is--
Trend is trending.
Okay, let's make them try to make sense of this mess, we're now bearish, and
with my
sense of it, hold up wait a minute, that's such difficult price actually makes
sense of,
and price is like this, it's so difficult to read, so I'll just mumble jumbo,
so we'll
put the same structural look until you get broken, and you get broken here, and
you have
a three kind of pullback, and then you break, and so technically,
but we won't have been turned out that right,
although thank you, I hope you haven't just taken me out at a larger loss than
I think
you have, Mr. Zeller, let me just make sure that you haven't slipped me in back
testing,
please, thank you.
Thank you.
I know it can be really annoying as well, like having to fill out all the
details and
stuff when you just want to keep testing, but it's-- it's the details that give
you the
data, the devil is in the details, I don't know what's going on here, that's 5
a.m.,
have we missed anything?
This is really horrible price action, whoa, okay, okay, this is one of those
predicaments
again, isn't it, one of those predicaments because you see, we shift bearish
upon the
breaketh of this loath, that shall be correcteth, and then, theneth, it's about
waiting for
that continuation in New York session, which actually occurs right here, soeth,
if thou
shalt enter thou trade, which I doeth not have to likeeth, thou shalt enter
thou trade
here, and thou shalt put their stop-loss at New York opening the price, which
thou
shall remind the viewers that he doeth not like this trade, this is how I have
to entertain
myself sometimes, we tag into the trade, the trade gives us a signal to go to
thou break
even, but this area is still mitigated, thou shalt now go to break even, and
thou shall
take a break even, and thou shalt be okay with this, and then, thou shalt get
another
opportunity to reenter the trade, and thou shalt use this favor you got, and I
don't
actually remember what happens from here, but I'm pretty sure it doesn't go in,
tag
us in, but this is a little bit out of my comfort zone, I will be honest with
you,
thou shalt get tagged into their position, thou shalt check the news, interest
rate decisions
at two, and thou shalt take a stop-loss, which is honestly unsurprising,
because thou thou
should, I don't like that, it's a little bit, yeah, type of setup, I want to
make a note
about that, like basically when, oh you know it would have been a good idea, if
we added
a new category and called it, flag for review, do you know how good of idea
that would have
been if we did that months ago?
[end]
.
No comment, no comment, that was interest rates and what not, oh boy, oh boy,
oh boy,
now we're going to predicament, I can already see the Thursday 19th, so that
was FOMC economic
projections, so that was a fairly interest rate decisions, and honestly I
really don't
like this because this leaves me in a predicament that I don't agree with at
all, which is that
technically price just broke structure or changed character, whatever you want
to call
it, and then gave up all back, and this became bullish, but I don't believe in
that, I believe
that that is a hoax, to be totally honest I don't trust it, man I wish I didn't
show
those, because if you look at that candle, I think it's very obvious that that
is in
a minute, that that is a manipulation candle, and when price manipulates so
aggressively
in one direction, it's usually because price wish earth to trade earth in the
oppose of
direction, so I fundamentally disagree that we have shifted bullish, and it's a
huge
trading leg, which means that we may get several days inside of the trading
range, and I have
a decision to make, well I'm obviously not going to be able to trade bullish,
because
if I trade bullish then this one will only be taken out, and I believe that the
market
is bearish, and I love this point of interest here, this inverted fair value
gap, perfectly
caused by this FOMC economic projections, which unintentionally just so happens
to manipulate
all of this liquidity, and liquidity set up previous highs, and then just
reverse, in
the opposite direction, for no apparent reason, just because that tells me that
price is going
to react from this level, and trade lower, and I would like to make money off
that belief,
so I am going to, which means I will consider this market to be bearish, and I
will also
have to tag discretion in my approach of doing so, which means that I am
officially looking
for shorts, as of right now, oh goody, apologies if you start seeing me
randomly saying, or
whatever, I am trying to keep myself sane, okay, well maybe we are going to
trade higher,
I don't think so, I think that anything above this high is now purely for the
purpose of
rebalancing and mitigating that position, it's 4.30, it's 4.30 in the morning,
we have
no news, we have no news on Friday either, and then it's Monday, well New York
has no
news, but we are at the tip of the iceberg, and we bearish it, apparently we
bearish now,
first New York opens like this, and then continues this not tradable
technically, now it's not,
you would see a boom boom, I am going to be one of them predicaments again, I
don't like,
yeah, I just don't see the purpose of trading this, because it is with my
expectation that
price is going to come back and fill this value up, probably come back to think
about
these orders and then trade from there, so this shall be a trade that shall be
tagged
for review, because I don't believe in this, I believe that this is foolish
behavior, why
would one trade at that point of the price leg, it doesn't make any sense, who
on earth
would do such a thing, it's not over yet, don't be getting all, I told you so,
oh that's
a bunch of liquidity, that's only a one to nine restaurant reward, Jesus, I may
well
indeed move my stop-loss to breakeethen at this point, I think, that's a
session over,
I would kindly like to move my position to breakeethen, please, thank you very
much,
well, I mean I still don't like it, and I'm still flagging it for review, and
it still
doesn't make money, sometimes you just have to work small, this would be a lull
continuation
and it would be from a strong point of interest in my, oh yeah, wait it's also
technically
discretion, here's New York, the trend is debatable, the structure flow is
irrelevant,
yes, yes, thank you very much, this goes to London, oh would you look at that,
we're
back in this area, can you just sweep that for me, thank you, and then if you
can just
come down here a little bit, if you haven't already, no, could you just maybe
come down
here just a little bit, yeah, no, yeah, don't play with me, thank you very much
, and then
if I could just maybe enter here, and then maybe, just maybe not have such a
large stop
plus, please, that would be incredible, maybe I can have my stop plus, I don't
know, here
for example, if it's possible, I'm just kind of, you just keep me in the trade,
if you do
go in my direction, I quite like this up, if you could be so kind, and then if
you could
just quickly just give me a little snap and a flick, that'd be great, exactly,
and then
if you could just trade lower, thank you, and then, oh no, okay, could you just
just
come to hear that at least, just go here, don't turn around, don't look back,
and then
just maybe come here, don't turn around, don't look back, and then if, and only
if,
you're feeling generous, just come here, I mean it's up to you, but if I was
you, I would,
you'd make a lot of people happy, wrong way, thank you, wrong way, wrong way,
we're not
going back there, New York session, New York, come on, we have no news, New
York, you do
me well, come on, be nice, that's what I'm talking about, you see that, that is
, wait,
is that tradable, I mean, not really, but if price comes back then maybe, let's
see,
all you've got to do is just trade here, you could just go to here, let's take
profit
put away, I'll take that, and then what I need you to do is, if you could just
visit him
as well, not that way, not that way, I don't want to click it because I know it
's going
to stop us, oh boy, I'm playing with fire right now, okay, we've got 5k, we've
locked
in, we've definitely, we're definitely profitable, so can you stay away from
that price level
please, that's the weekend, because from here things get techy, now again,
depending on you
as a trader, I don't have the liquidity, but I have so much conviction on this
setup,
although it doesn't seem like it, I mean in terms of like, the actual structure
of everything,
and price trading lower, although I don't like that 4 hour candle, well, we're
at break
even, Monday the 23rd, we have H-COP, and we know that H-COP can move from
market, doesn't
mean we can't trade, but it means we do need to be careful, I don't even know
what the
structure is anyhow.
If I am not mistaken, which I honestly could be, because this is an easy price
to root,
I see one more, quicker, we're at run for.
No, I'm not mistaken, I don't know what to say, no, so we're bullish from here,
which
means technically we need to see price for a trade all the way down here.
We have H-COP in around 25 minutes, my expectation for price is lower, I can
bring my stop to
here for example, I don't see why price would then trade back up there, price
is going to
trade up to this high, it's going to trade above these highs most likely.
We could look at taking another pocket of profit off at this low, another 5R, H
-COP hasn't
even dropped yet, let's go ahead and close 50% more, what does actual H-COP do,
let's
close a little more, and then just run to here if you feel like it, at this
point you
can just remove to already well into profit, don't even matter, but this would
still give
an extra 3.5% pretty much, it's untradable anyway,
all week low, if we're looking for shorts, we could continue shorting from here
and kind
of scaling essentially, is that structured correct?
This has been longer than undesired, price shifted bullish here, price
continued bullish
here, and then we shifted bearish, and then we continued bearish, this is all
really difficult
to read but we continue again, we continue again, we shift bullish, yep, that's
tradable,
that is tradable, we can look at scaling back into this, 24 for September, and
the actual
swing low is down here, this is a lot of expect price to take out, do we have
any news 24th,
IFO at 4, let's see, 245 tagged, and stops, 310, and we're about to get news.
And I could trade high above that high, we have no New York news, let me just
quickly
journal this, we might perhaps get more shorts in New York, yep, yep, yep, yep,
yep.
What's up is this, this is a frank sweep reversal, point of interest is weak
session
is London, trend is still debatable, structure flow, it's also really difficult
to try and
explain, you know what I mean, all of these become a little bit, 245,
everything that's
now in this is also has to be a discretion, which is really annoying, but at
least we'll
understand the characteristics as to why, okay, let's guess New York, well,
that may just
be another opportunity, 958, and then we may be able to get it, structure is
correct,
where would we enter from, I would almost definitely enter from that M5, or
block with
my stops at the highs, we still have this position running as well, a very
small amount
of it, it's not incredible restore reward, but we'll get tagged in because it's
pretty
much already tagged in.
Well, wish it was three minutes later, I'm just kidding, we're an hour and a
half and
we haven't finished September, can we hurry up?
This is a... territory discretion, but it's also a New York stream law,
structure is debatable,
no news apparently, execution window, nice turn, flag review, no, well, that's
that
also, well, I guess we were wrong on structure then, we obviously had the
reaction and we
still made some of the decent amount of money I think, we broke even on this
trade I think,
break even, this was winner, winner, winner, that's one trade though, which
accounts for
about probably five R, so break even, plus five, four, minus one, minus one, I
don't
know what that's about, ah, that's what that's about, don't mind, I think we, I
haven't
made money on the opinion, the question is, is there to be a missile underneath
in the
opposite direction, technically no, maybe even a loss, maybe even another loss,
no, no,
nope, nope, nope, no, I think it ends up being the better decision, even if it
didn't
perfectly take the lows, I think that price still did at least somewhat of what
I expected
it to do, which is after a sweep like that you're expecting a reversal, price
just ends
up then going back into here and then continuing, which is fine, also goes to
show that you
don't actually need to be right to make money, you just need to have good risk
management,
so it bullish, it's not a shift, nope, it's 25th, no news, almost done, that's
a low
sweep, does tradable, I guess, let's have a look at this for a second, before
we even
gain 20 of that, first and foremost, the structure is correct, again that's
technically the
confirmation, the confirmation is in the M1 pulling back and continuing, if I
was to
long this, which is really weird considering that I would have to long, I would
expect
that price to be a bearish along, but it would be basically this M15 order
block, even my
stop-loss, I wouldn't want to put my stop-loss at these lows, I don't think it
makes sense,
I think this low, many place this low nicely, this is, this should be the level
, price
respects, if price doesn't respect this level then, what else is there, it's
also a risk
towards things like, we ask it a lot, I can't really get to break even, if
price continues
rally and then maybe, no, if I'm going to break even here, there's no news,
fair enough,
let's, low continuation, yeah, no, low continuation, what's the actual market
doing, point of
time, okay, at least trend is technically change of character, wait a second,
that also would
have threw off the other structure, but if that was a change of character, then
that's
a break of structure, that was a break of structure, then that's a change of
character,
and then these, these are bearish, these bearish shorts are technically not
discretionary
if it's a follow structure, I'm going to keep them as they are but, just for
context, yeah,
what, change of character, change of character, pull back, so change of
character, no news
oh, by the way, we're officially at 100% return, which means now every 1% that
we risk is
technically 2%, because the account is doubled, which is like, hopefully it
doesn't skew the
person of the data, because now literally every, every loss is, every loss is
technically
2% of starting balance, it's still one lot of risk, obviously, but I mean, what
's the
important thing, I guess the important thing is that, you understand how to
play the model,
okay, very interesting price delivery, now we're on to the 26th, we have GDP,
durable
goods, power speech, this is going to be one of them again, honestly the most
draining
part of this is just checking the 1-minute structure, that's the most draining
part,
now where do we answer from, this encompasses the buy to sell and the favor you
go, because
now everyone lot of risk is $20,000, decent, decent, think breakeven for sure,
think technically
also we have to look at 5R, we'll see, you've got to be kidding me right, good
management,
you're annoying trade, but I mean, good management, but I also really mean, I'm
really so intrigued,
and you're going to have a man, just don't let them make you go and talk.
That's a nine.
New York, New York is here, now we also have a set up in New York I think, yeah
, maybe
this one will do it, oh look at this, it's an invite wherever you go, it's a
nice sweep
of London, probably shoot this M15 order block, 26, oh wait a second, we don't
want to do
that, we don't want to do that, even third pal speaking in like 50 minutes, I
'll probably
give that a miss as well, yeah, we move, the Friday 27th, core PCE, inflation
rate at 245,
so let's wait, that's inflation rate, we can't do anything about that, we can't
do anything
in London, say for September, are we bearish, so bearish, I'm curious
before we start going into that, we are obviously at the premium of the most
premium
of the premium of the premium of the price tag, the London session has swept
below above
New York, we have so much sell-side liquidity, by the way, like all of that
sell-side liquidity,
all of that is sell-side, that is sell-side, I wanted to trade this, obviously
it's out
of my window but the shift here, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, that's why I
wanted to trade,
M1 structure, bearish here, continuation, continuation, continuation bullish,
pullback,
1, 2, 3, shift, buy to sell,
you can sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy to sell,
buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy to
sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to
sell, buy
to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy
to sell,
buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy to
sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to
sell, buy
to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy
to
sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to
sell,
buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy
to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy
to
sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell, buy to sell,
average loss is less than 1%. I'm really annoyed now that I did,
I've been consistent with risk on 1% of current balance. I wish I just did
everything on
starting balance because the day it would be way better to read because it
would be way more
reflective of a base metric of R, for example, because every every one lot of
risk is $10,000
period. And so average losing trade is $13,000, but the problem is is at some
point we was risking
$10,500 a trade, at some point we were risking $20,000 a trade. So that's
really annoying,
and they are multiple,
they are multiple metric isn't working for us.
I don't understand this. How is there 40 trades with Narn?
Does it make sense? And there's not 40 that's 1R to 1.9R either.
Only one trade was a loss lower than 1R, like that's incorrect, it's inaccurate
.
It's really annoying.
So look at our setups. So discretion is net negative. We've taken eight trades
on discretion,
and they have been negative. Had one trade that was a winner.
But where are the winners that were also tagged up?
Yeah, I'm not sure.
That was the discretion slash.
We'll come from Cleveland the day or the end. The majority of it's accurate. It
would have been
just easier to read if I just use the base metric as 1R.
But I mean, what you can see is a 3.18 profit factor. An average losing trade
is 5 times
5.3 times the average losing trade. Average winning trade is 5.3 times larger
than the average losing
trade. 41% of our day then the win. 37.5% of our trades are winners.
So far so good.
And I still think that there are a lot of, I still think that there's a lot of
development, New York session, still far outperforming
London. In fact, arguably almost all of our profitability has come from New
York in some
sense. Now that is because I think that London, there needs to be some
optimization in the London
setups. But this is proven to be the case that the less is more, like the
profit factor is nowhere
near as good in London. 23% win rate in London.
23% win rate in London. 61% win rate in New York. An 8.8 profit factor.
23% win rate in London. That's our data with New York only.
Healthy equity curve.
But like I said, there's definitely some optimization for certain setups.
There's a lot of refinements.
A most traded model
is the London sweep Asia. And you can see it's barely profitable. So there's 22
trades in here.
So what this means is there's 25% win rate. It's profitable, but it's returned
5% in February
March, April, May, June, July, August, September, 5% in 8 months, which is
terrible. But there's
just optimization to be done. And so what do you do? You go through your data
and you start looking
at all the trades. And you start finding characteristics of them. You can
replay your trade.
By the entry of the position.
You can replay your trade. You can pretty sure you can edit your stuff in here
as well if you need
to. I can then replay these trades. You can clean this up as well.
You can add everything on it. You can replay it. Or you can also just go back
to the chart
and replay it on the chart and just find characteristics. Now it's just about
taking notes
on every sink.
Then it's just literally, like I said, at that point it's about identifying
the what's working, what's not working, make changes. What's working, what's
not working, make
changes. But yeah, so far New York is crushing.
London needs work. But I know there's optimization in here. Because right now
basically I'm just
taking every single trade that's pro trend that sweeps Asia that reverses.
There's distinctions
to be made. But yeah, I mean so far it's undeniably a beast model. And feel
free to like I've said
a million times the purpose of this is like you being able to do this yourself
and understand
the process. Because if you can develop this skill set to understand what we're
doing right now,
to be able to do it yourself, you're unstoppable. This is what 99% of people
will never tell you.
It's what you've probably never learned before. And it's what will actually
make you profitable
long term. Your ability to go and do this, go in, collect the data, and run all
your tests and
understand how to structure things, how to organize things, how to make changes
. If you can do this
there's nothing that you can't develop and you also don't have to wait for me.
Like I'm not
spending all day every day developing and refining and tuning models. That's
not the point of
trading I'm at at this point. But you may be, you may be able to be faster than
me. So yeah,
without waffling on so far so good let's kind of keep the keep the momentum go.